spacex has under its belt some insane
milestones that continue to awe and
inspire fans of elon musk what started
as a privately funded venture by a man
with a dream is now the us government's
go-to for vehicles for space missions
they are the first to develop reusable
rockets something previously thought
impossible they are also the first
private space flight company to dock at
the international space station the
first private company to send a liquid
rocket fuel into orbit and well
you get it they have a lot of first to
their name a company like that needs an
impressive headquarters where designers
engineers rocket fuel developers and
more can collaborate and sometimes crash
just like how elon musk is known to
sleep on the floor of his factory let's
dive in but before we begin welcome back
to our channel make sure you hit the
subscribe button and ring the bell so
you're notified every time we upload a
new video spacex milestones
they've had quite the year of success in
2020 and that will no doubt continue in
2021 since its founding in 2002 spacex
has been consistently knocking it out of
the park giving its competitors a run
for their money in the interest of
sustainability and of course reducing
cost spacex found a way to reuse its
rockets and in march of 2017 spacex
relaunched its falcon 9 rocket with a
satellite on board and successfully
recovered it again by landing in the
atlantic ocean it even made the dragon
capsule reusable it launched a tesla
roadster into space which has now been
up there for three years in 2020 spacex
launched its first ever astronaut in a
dragon capsule which docked at the iss
on the 31st of may and the same
astronauts returned to earth in the
endeavor demo 2 capsule in august 2020
they conducted their 100th launch and
celebrated the sixth use of their falcon
9 booster in august 2020 as well the
crew dragon launched four people to iss
on its first fully operational mission
in november 2020. this marked the first
nasa certified commercial human
spacecraft system in history most
recently in may 2021 spacex blew its
competitors out of the water for the
nasa moon contract were there protests
from their biggest competitor blue
origin sure what did spacex do about it
they launched a rocket it was the first
launch of their starship prototype for
moon and mars now planned for september
of this year spacex will launch its
first all-private all-civilian orbital
mission and by the end of this year it
will have sent starship on its maiden
voyage by 2024 it will have sent cargo
up to mars along with 100 people to
establish a civilization spacex
headquarters
with all the exciting things they have
coming up it's hardly a surprise that
their facility factory and offices
included spans 500 000 square feet
located in hawthorne california just
outside los angeles this space was once
a manufacturing site for the 747
aircraft now it's where spacex designs
and builds eighty percent of their
rockets but you don't grasp the sheer
scale of their operations until you step
inside the mission control room is
something out of a movie featuring all
the software and computer networks
necessary to communicate with the
rockets and capsules they launch into
space just across from mission control
is the area where they conduct all their
inspections the space is climate
controlled since different metals expand
and contract at different temperatures a
consistent 68 degrees keeps them stable
and allows them to perform the minutest
precision measurements in the precision
control area it cools down by a lot the
robots and tools here inspect parts down
to the thousandth of an inch to make
sure everything is working just like it
should the server room contains about
500 processors to compute fluid dynamics
and carry out finite element analysis
and it acts as a service storage for
their solid 3d modeling but things get
really impressive when you step into the
manufacturing facility a giant conveyor
belt of components for the rocket zip
around the space and these are all parts
that have made it through inspections
and precision controls we've seen before
now they're here just waiting to be put
together by highly trained engineers
unsurprisingly spacex has one of the
most incredible factories in the world
how impressive well their facility can
build you a starship rocket in just 72
hours this area also has a shake room
and a stress test facility the shake
room simulated the enormous acoustic and
vibrational loads that components
experience when they are shot up into
space if they make it through the ordeal
in this room they make it to the next
stage but according to musk it's where
most of their stuff ends up breaking in
the stress testing facility the parts
are put in different environments to
check if they can perform in the most
extreme situations but it's not all
about parts and components software
plays a huge role too with software
engineers carrying out daily tests of
the system and running thousands of ai
simulations to predict every possible
outcome of a launch as employees working
in one of the greatest companies in the
world it's only fair that everybody gets
to watch their rockets launch into space
for that reason there is an entire
section of the headquarters covered in
glass to allow viewers front row seats
to the show elon musk's office
but where does the brains behind the
entire operation sit unsurprisingly elon
doesn't have a sprawling office with
end-to-end carpets and a wall aquarium
that's too bond villainesque truth is
elon barely has an office at all instead
he walks around the factory and
interacts with his workers on a
day-to-day basis he'll sit and work on
his laptop in a common area and often
eats during his meetings too since he
barely gets any time to himself musk
believes in transparency and openness in
his workspace because doors limit
communication that is with the exception
of their conference rooms whose glass
walls turn opaque when they are meeting
with investors clients and customers the
upcoming texas facility
don't be too surprised though when elon
musk packs up his entire facility
california imposes the highest personal
income tax in the country on its
wealthiest residence and given how elon
musk is now the richest man in the world
this definitely has an impact on him he
has already moved quite a chunk of his
tesla manufacturing operations to texas
and spacex is soon to follow he has
already invested a great deal in the
area even donated millions to the local
school district the new starship rocket
is already being constructed in boca
chica village austin it might be easier
for him too since he is constantly
commuting from texas to california on
his private gulfstream g650 jet along
with taking frequent trips to his
gigafactories in germany and china what
do you think of the spacex headquarters
will the one in texas be equally as
great let us know in the comments below
if you enjoyed the video hit the like
button and check out more on the simply
tech channel thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time